vacances alors je peux vous dire
j'aimais bien retrouver mon émission
préférée tous les soirs voilà et c'est
vrai que toute la journée je travaillais
mes cours parce que voilà à 19 heures un
petit peu de détente jusqu'à 21h puis
21h ont retravaillé et après ma bras
quant à bac + 14 ans et s'appelle pas du
racket sur soi le bac lui doublé quatre
ans soit le nom mais c'est vrai on peut
pas être fainéant et bien travaillé
comme l'étude du droit mais j'étais venu
ici à bordeaux c'est la fac de talence à
bordeaux au tour du web j'étais vous me
demandez je vous dis j'étais huissier de
justice
non toi tu es si oui ça l'est mais c'est
toi qui attaquent à la porte de castaldi
continuer
ça montre des trucs incroyables été
comme carole comme quand j'ai fait du
droit aussi mais il faut choisir un
huissier commis ouais mais lui c'est un
méchant très méchant faut être un gros
gros méchant non
ce résultat est belle à 10 ans dirait on
dirait qu'elle aurait exciter le bras de
l'huissier des chaînes thématiques
[Applaudissements]
durant ce soir sur m6 à l'époque aux
bonnes choses j'avais tout donné
tian bonjour madame paraît-il que vous
n'avez pas payer certaines factures
c'est ça oui je m'en vais voir un petit
peu votre mobilier un vrai mois donne
que cette porte
le mobilier donc ici c'est tabou c'est
tombé le lingerie
j'ai bien tapé contre l'habitude comme
et dessus mais j'ai fait je préfère mon
bac juste avant j'ai arrêté juste avant
le bac en visite à tartu stand aquatique
s'est interposé après face à toi y'a un
truc qui s'interpose et moi j'ai arrêté
pour rien moi j'aurais pu faire une
grande carrière
de quoi de quoi d'ailleurs moi oui
j'espère comptable un gros après que
j'étais en expertise comptable et meiwey
vous dire que quand je rentrais dans la
caste est comme ça